that alone is kind of like to your point
here where
if you're a creator with an audience
with credibility if you've done
something if you're actually good at a
skill
yeah you can get to a million dollars a
year of profit
uh not just revenue doing it as an
individual course creator
yes and the path is quite
straightforward the tactics are
are simple but uh it's basically
i feel like i can rule the world i know
i could be what i want to
i put my law in it like no days off on
the road let's travel never looking back
all right everyone what's happening we
have a good episode but before we get to
it please do me a favor
click the subscribe button on itunes and
the follow button
on spotify last week we got a ton more
spotify listens because they're doing
something i think there's like a pop-up
right now that shows to people when you
listen to the podcast that asks if you
want to follow
and uh anyway i want to see if that's
working so go ahead and click
follow on spotify and then click
subscribe on itunes and the reason why
is the more you click that the higher we
go up in the rankings higher we open the
rankings the more lessons we get the
more listens
we get the more cool that we can do
so do that now in this episode we're
going to talk about
course businesses um of course business
is something that a lot of people
are interested in i think it's one of
the easiest ways to make a million
dollars a year
uh but we're also going to talk about
how companies are making 100 million a
year doing it so
go ahead give us a listen we're going to
talk all about the course businesses
it's going to start in just a second
and make sure to click subscribe click
follow
and we'll talk to you soon we got a lot
of cool stuff going on but how you doing
i'm good i'm still recovering from your
sick burn about my uh sweatshirt
[Laughter]
they'll see on video it's it's it's not
that it's bad
it's just that it would have been a lot
better if you wore it as like a
nine-year-old in 1994
i look like a skateboarder who got his
birthday present
and uh you know a 12 year old
skateboarder who got his birthday
present
and then abrayu clapped back at sam and
told him he looks like a knight
who's wearing the like chain link stuff
that goes under your armor
you look like the extra from the disney
movie brink
okay i have not seen that but you look
like a 90s
disney movie extra dude i wish that
would be an upgrade from my
reality have you um do you read books
i can't tell if this is another burn
well that's a transition to a real
question
do i read books do you know how to read
yeah i read books
how many books do you read
[Laughter]
i'm not this is like real i don't know
how much do you bench press
i read like i'm reading like a book all
the time like it doesn't have one book
that's going at any given time
probably read i don't know three four a
year do you um
when you're reading it do you feel like
you absorb it
yeah i intentionally read slow and i
reread
and i take notes so that's what i'm
doing now instead of
like you know how like do you know who
ryan holiday is
i know about him yeah i love ryan he's
cool but he reads like
five books a week and that's popular
that people will say like for their new
year's resolution i'm gonna read 50
books this year
right and i'm like damn that's hard just
to do
but like do you learn anything and what
i'm trying to do now is only read two or
three books a year but i'm
i'm like quizzing myself i'm trying to
master it and it's been really hard
so what i do is i get a bunch of books
like i'll buy a book every three days
probably if anything looks interesting i
have an unlimited book budget for myself
and i've had this for a long time where
i just decided okay i'm not gonna be
i'm not gonna have a budget i do the
same thing by the way it's and so i just
instantly buy it on my phone i use the
kindle app on my phone
to read i have a kindle i have physical
books sometimes but
i'm all the phone is always with me so i
like that better i end up reading more
there
and um what i do is i will
i'll read like five percent of 50 books
in a year
right like i will just pick up a book
i'll start skimming through it
and uh i just assume that most books are
bad
and so i i i'm very i do not complete
95 of the books that i read that i start
and i think that's totally okay
the book has to actually like be
interesting or grab me or say something
interesting for me to
try to finish it but then once i do read
a book that i like i will reread that
book
multiple times over the years like i'll
reread the books
same i i do the same thing i use it as a
reference book and i reread it a two
times
um i want to ask you so today i want to
talk to you about
course businesses and i went down a
rabbit hole and i called someone right
before the podcast in order to get intel
and get insights
it looks like you have a ton of ideas
but can we start with something really
easy which is you got into an argument
with someone on twitter
that's what you have listed here and i
am you you you alluded to it
a week ago what happened i don't know
what you're talking about
okay so uh all right i'm gonna try to
do this without getting without
restarting the fight
um i tweeted out that i said you know um
i don't even know what i said exactly i
basically said elon musk
and jake paul have um yes i said i said
elon musk
you know sells cars and uh launches
rockets and raises money and
does all this stuff and you know tesla
never runs a commercial
jake paul is like does the same he's
going to sell millions of dollars of
pay-per-views for this boxing match that
he is coming up
uh without a commercial and i said the
best marketers don't spend a dime
right just kind of like a an observation
it's not like
obviously and also like a cute sound
bite tweet yeah just a sound bitey thing
obviously many marketers spend money and
they're great at it and it's a smart
thing
i do i spend money when i advertise too
it's great so that's not really the
point the point was
some people are able to hijack people's
attention in the news
and have done very well with it right so
i tweet that out
doesn't even seem like that
controversial of a statement to me um
move on with my life and then a
few people start comment a bunch of
people were like yeah true blah blah
and then a couple people comment like um
you know yeah but jake paul's an
okay fair enough doesn't matter to me
um and then one person who's a writer
for the new york times
basically says um i can't believe you
i i can pull up the tweet i should pull
up the tweet because this is gonna be
stupid if i uh and while you're doing
that the person you're talking about her
name is taylor lorenz she works for the
new york times
a lot of people in the tech world and a
lot of people in general
uh really dislike her and i'm i i
actually
let's be objective here a lot of people
really love her so
we don't always want to go to the
negative side but sure okay so i have my
stuff in front of me and by the way i
don't have her tweet because she now has
blocked me but
uh so that's the end of the story all
right so i said elon is pumping dogecoin
on saturday night live while the paul
brothers are raking in tens of millions
just by stealing floyd mayweather's hat
while the camera is on
the greatest marketers don't spend a
dime uh by the way did you see the hat
thing the gotcha hats
so funny yeah so funny okay so uh
if you haven't seen it jake paul's older
brother logan is scheduled to fight
floyd mayweather
logan paul is a youtuber floyd
mayweather probably the great greatest
boxer ever
it's not even going to be close it's not
even a it's not even a
like a real contest it's like 2001 odds
yeah it's like celebrity death match you
have two celebrities disagreeing to go
punch each other but like one of them is
actually a professional puncher
yeah and um so anyways but they have to
sell the fight so in the press
conference you know they have to pretend
like
oh i'm talking trash like i'm gonna beat
you and you're talking trash like you're
gonna beat me
anyways jake paul stole the show this
wasn't trending very well because
it's so one-sided not a lot of people
wanted to go buy this because there's
not much intrigue of what's going to
happen
the only people want to buy it are just
people who want to see a bit of a circus
and so
jake paul goes up to floyd mayweather
and they're talking and they're
like um you know i could beat you up you
could beat me up and then jake paul goes
gotcha hat and then just took his hat
and ran away like an absolute third
grader
on the playground funny as hell uh of
course
you know to ham it up floyd miller tries
to go fight him because he took his hat
and then there's like you know 70 people
all holding their camera phones up
recording the thing and it's just
reading that show yeah so that that went
viral that goes that gets on every you
know blog and that goes viral on social
media some people think it's stupid some
people think it's
whatever doesn't matter what your
opinion is they got a bunch of attention
from it so that's all i was pointing out
um and in fact jake paul then tripled
down on it
which was he uh he did the gotcha hat
thing it goes viral on social media
while it's going viral
he has this merch guy gotcha hat hats uh
puts it up on his store
sells out of gotcha hats gotcha hat hats
and then he gets a tattoo on his leg
that says gotcha hat
and post that that goes viral that jake
paul got a tattoo of the thing that just
happened so he got a double pump
a second pump of news pr out of it so i
was just pointing out that
these guys are good at marketing they're
good at marketing themselves they're
self-promoters
by definition you really can't disagree
that the paul brothers are not good
self-promoters they
self-promoted themselves yeah huge
anyways
a bunch of people say yes and then a
couple people are like
um you know these are pranksters they
shouldn't be labeled as great marketers
don't set them up as anything to be
emulated
um basically like don't say they're good
because people
what they were saying was like people
follow you well they were basically
saying
well sean they're bad people and you're
like yeah i don't care that's not the
point
they could be the worst person on earth
i'm just saying i'm just showing that
they get eyeballs
yeah they're effective at marketing
that's all i said yeah it's like saying
like a like a cigarette company could be
a great marketer who cares if you think
cigarette
is good or bad and so this writer for
the new york times basically takes us as
an opportunity to come in and
promote her own article in the new york
times that says i covered the story
about the
sexual assault allegations against him
so you you know you really basically i
don't know exactly she said because
again she blocked me i can't go read it
but
it said something to the effect of um
like it's messed up to
um to promote them or say something like
to be
saying that they're good or whatever
when they're actually jerks they're bad
guys they're they're
whatever this guy's been accused of
sexual assault
so i kind of i don't even remember what
i said back but i kind of went back and
forth and i was just saying
what you just said i am not saying that
they're good humans i'm not saying
they're great citizens i didn't say they
should be president
i said they're good at marketing i don't
really see how that's arguable
and then you know they clap back again
and said you know
basically you're a jerk for saying that
he's good and um
and so a couple things happen first is
dude i i like r
kelly could be a great singer and also a
horrible human being
yes and so so one of them was like you
know is there really anything to learn
from these guys
um blah blah blah and so anyways they're
going back and forth i
and i'm i'm getting agitated at this
point and so the new york times writer
she goes she said something that was
like again just like trying to like
virtue signal and i just replied i go
she was she she said something like
i don't think he i don't think he knows
the point he's i don't think he
he's making the point he thinks he's
making talking like replying to me
talking about me but as if i'm like not
in the room anyways i thought that was
like a weird way of saying it and so i
just go you are the jake paul of
journalism
oh my gosh
got blocked uh instantly um and you know
a bunch of people
were that got a big reaction out of
people now i thought this was
the perfect kill shot why because that's
not an insult to me i'm
so first of all it's true her brand of
self-promoting herself as a journalist
is confrontation she gets in
confrontations with
keith for boy with biology with neva
with whoever right she just goes and
picks fights on twitter with mark
andreessen
and so she she goes to the biggest names
she
creates controversy picks fights and
then she also like then
as soon as they sort of attack back then
she turns that into a story which is
big bad tech is bullying me um and so i
was just pointing out that actually her
form of
self-promotion is the same as jake
paul's he went to floyd mayweather
agitated him picked got gotcha hat and
used that con
controversy in that confrontation to
build his own brand so
i was a correct in the way identifying
her own playbook of
self-promotion b it's not an insult to
me
again i have no problem with jake paul
jake paul came on the podcast
um you know i i think this guy's a good
marketer i think that
i i don't take such a black and white
look at people and say that
this person is good and this person is
evil and this person is you know like i
just don't think that
the world is that black or white and so
uh anyways i wasn't trying to answer her
but she took it as an insult of course
because that's why it was the perfect
one-liner uh i was able to insult her
without even insulting her
and so um so anyways that was the
confrontation and then
uh yeah i got you know a bunch of dms
from people and then
you know people of my company were like
hey can you not like
pick fights with journalists and i was
like okay i'm sorry i really wasn't
trying to pick a fight with the
journalist initially
oh that's pretty funny um well that's a
good story
i still have no problem with her i
actually think she's a really effective
marketer of herself too like i know her
name
i don't know anyone any other tech
journalist name i genuinely think
she does a very good job at promoting
herself by covering interesting and
controversial topics like she
was covering tick tock early on and then
also her brand of sort of like taking it
to
the you know powerful people in tech i
view it as an effective form of
marketing i also think she's good at it
so it's
i really have no ill will but i did
think it was a cool
uh online i think that's a pretty good
one liner i didn't i
unfollowed like everyone on twitter i've
been spending less time on it because
it makes me angry but i wish i would
have seen that because that's pretty
well
by the way by the way this was the best
part all the white knights do you know
what a white knight is
yeah so for those who don't know white
knight is like sort of a
how would you describe it like someone
who like they don't
they don't necessarily care about the
topic they're just trying to act like
they're saving the day so
uh the girl likes them yeah it's
basically dudes online who come to the
rescue of women
to virtually signal how they are you
know such they are the good noble
supporters of
of good and evil whatever um so anyways
there's a bunch of white knights that
were in the thread that were like
yeah sean i can't believe you did this i
can't believe you would
give someone this platform first of all
jake paul has a 50 times bigger platform
than me
uh second of all um yeah i
that's my that is my platform i point
out things that are interesting or
you know i point out truths i'm not like
trying to toe the politically correct
line
and then i go to this guy's twitter i go
to his twitter the second retweet is
conor mcgregor has sold this many
millions of dollars of whiskey you know
he's promoting it
guess who also has a bunch of sexual
assault allegations against them right
now
conor mcgregor so he was allowed to
promote
that conor mcgregor i called him out i
go
dude i like you we've we've been
friendly before
but what a hypocrite look at your own
timeline dude you're saying this guy is
great
he goes honestly i just didn't i didn't
know that about conor
and so it's and then a bunch of people
were eye-rolling like oh you didn't know
good yeah
okay cool like you're literally know
that everyone knows that that guy like
punched an older guy in the bar like
this has been on the news yeah yeah you
thought conor mcgregor was sort of you
know
goody two shoes yeah right like this
guy's been in the news
he's been in jail he's done all this
stuff and so i just thought that that
was the
the classic hypocrisy of of people on
twitter
well i uh i didn't see it i'm happy i
know the story
i'm and i'm what i i love that you do
that i think that is great and i think
you should continue to do it hopefully
you won't you won't not do that because
you were asked not to but
we'll see do you want to talk about the
course business because i actually
i didn't get into it but i i saw a
company that i think is kind of silly
for what they're trying to disguise
themselves as
but i actually think it's good for what
it re it really is and i want to bring
it up but i
did a ton of research and i know that
you're interested in courses as well
yeah
okay i'm fully teased i go for it what
is it what's the company
okay so today uh the for this little
segment let's talk about the course
business the education business whatever
i broke it down into four different
categories
but there's this company called i don't
know if it's called be on deck or on
deck
yeah it's called on deck the you the url
is beyonddeck.com
um it's actually really confusing what
they advertise themselves as
if you go to beyonddeck.com frankly i
didn't know what it was i didn't
understand it
i did some research i think i understand
it now um and
the way that i see it is it's a course
business so basically
you pay i don't even know the price
actually is it like 500
uh it's like hundreds of dollars i
believe and you sign up for it's over a
thousand dollars
it's over a thousand dollars is it under
two grand
yeah i think it ranges between one and
two grand something like that one or two
maybe one in three one and three grand
and you sign up to a cohort based class
meaning there's a start and an
end and they have got like 15 different
classes probably at this point
i got to stop you there's these aren't
it's not a class why why are you saying
it's a class
yeah that's what it is um you can you
can call it
there's no teacher there's no uh okay so
here's how i here here's here's how i
would describe it right so so we you you
know eric thornberg right he's
i don't know oh you don't know him okay
eric's good guy
he's he was early on at product hunt he
left and he's created a bunch of things
since then one of which was on deck
so the way he thinks about on deck and
the way he talks about it is
on deck is basically like a modern day
business school so why do people go to
business school
people go to business school because
they want to build a network
they want to maybe learn about business
and they're looking to kind of like
pivot their career in a different
direction right they were doing one job
they want to go to the next job they
don't know what it is they want to
change industries change roles change
whatever
change careers so business school is
this great pivot point to do that
so what on deck did was they sort of
made an unbundled and digital version of
that
um actually not even digital there's a
lot of in-person components to it so
what it is is
you um let's say they have a bunch of
different tracks but let's say you want
to go
into let's say you want to become an
angel investor and you're not an angel
investor today
so on deck is your pivot to do that you
apply to join you say great i'll pay the
to go to the on deck angels program
and yes there is some education they
bring in speakers who are angel
investors they'll talk about angel
investing that sort of thing
but it's basically a x-week program
for you to you know go from where you
are now to
that track that you want to be on and it
can be with angel investors it's a
little bit more like a course which
you're talking about which is
you're going to learn about a thing and
then by the end of it you can do it but
they
it started with just people who were on
deck to build their next company
i was like all right you don't know what
you're going to do next why don't you
join a group of other people who are
also thinking about their next
opportunities
maybe they have a great idea you could
join their team maybe you could find a
co-founder and and
do this here and it was just people who
were looking to make a change
and um and you would pay to basically
enhance
to join this to get a good network so
the network
is all kind of like other kind of like
just like if you go to harvard you're
getting other people who have a certain
caliber of
person who's going to go on to do a
certain caliber of things and
you pay to go be a part of like an
eight-week program or whatever to go
do that yeah that sounds like a class to
me
an eight-week program where you're
learning and talking
it's just a lot less about the learning
content side and it's a lot more about
the network that you want to build then
in that case i would say the likelihood
that they're going to be quite huge i
think is actually lower it would
actually be better if they were a course
business
because the problem with that is they're
either going to raise prices to be tens
of thousands or hundreds of thousands of
dollars a year
or they're gonna have to decrease the
standards of who they let in and keep
the price low and thus ruin their
network so let's talk about some of the
programs that they have right so they
have on deck founders that's i want to
go start a company
they have on deck first 50 which is i
want to become
i'm a talented operator i want to go
join a early stage company in the first
50 employees that's going to
that's going to be the next airbnb the
next whatever right uh there's on-deck
investors where you learn about angel
investing
there's on-deck podcasters where it's
like if you want to start and kind of
grow a podcast
join a batch of other people who want to
join to start a podcast
listen to speakers who are existing
successful podcasters
and by the end of it you'll have like
built up some momentum of now going down
this new path that you weren't on before
so let's just say who cares about on
deck
because it got me thinking about the
course business i think it's a course
business
you say it's not it doesn't really
matter what it is because that is what
got me interested
in the course business and the problem
with the course business is
when we say the course business
oftentimes people will categorize
anything that's even remotely related to
course into the same category
and that's actually false that's not
that's not how it should be
um and so what i want to talk about is
the four categories and let's talk about
why each one is interesting and so i'll
just briefly list what those are so the
first one
is basically one person or a smallish
company making a handful of courses
that's like our friend jack butcher
right that's like ramit satya our good
friend
or my good friend ramit sethi this and
we're gonna i'll go back and we'll
actually talk about what makes that
what it is the second are platforms so
things like udemy
um things like teachable a lot of people
say this is the course business that's
not a course business
that's a tech company that uh makes
technology so people
can create and sell courses i'm not even
gonna talk about that because
that's a totally different category even
though people do sometimes refer to it
like uh this category
or with courses the third one is the
master classes of the world
these are another example is this
company called the great courses
these are businesses that create
hundreds eventually
of different courses and they go and
sell to consumers for 100 bucks to 200
300 a year and the fourth one is
b2b companies that sell education to
companies and so
a company like that is pluralsight which
sold for three billion dollars and does
something like 500 million dollars in
revenue
there's a there's a few other there's
coursera there's um
there's actually a handful of them that
i didn't know about but in researching
there's a handful that do
300 to 600 million dollars a year in
sales multi-billion dollar business now
i want to go through
each one and explain what makes them
tick or at least what i think make them
tick and and
in order to do this i went and talked to
my friend ryan dice ryan dice runs this
thing called digitalmarketer.com
and he he's been in the game for 20 plus
years and we kind of talked
through this so the first category is
these like single person creators i
think you're like that
um i'm not like that at the moment i
could probably easily become that
and um i i enjoy that and i actually
think that the path
to making a million dollars a year this
way is incredibly straightforward and
it's a very high likelihood
in term all all relative to starting a
business but it's like a really
high likelihood of making like a million
bucks a year it's very high likelihood
that you can make 200 000
a year um and so these are companies
like uh i will teach you to be rich
uh doc is that what it's called i'll
teach you to be rich.com
it's uh what you've done what what was
your newsletter called
the all access pass that wasn't quite uh
a course like
it's what i announced i don't know if
you saw this i tweeted out that i was
doing a course
yes yes and i said hey i'm gonna do a
course uh
on power writing basically like writing
for the real world and i just tweeted
out like
would you be interested here's what this
has helped this skill has helped me it's
helped me get jobs it's helped me
you know get investment it's helped me
grow my companies help me make money
so writing in the real world emails
tweets blogs
ads landing pages that type of writing
you know going from good to great is a
big difference
would you want to learn this i said it
would cost 400 bucks
for the first batch of people whoever
was like kind of the guinea pigs
let me know if you'd want to do this and
um i got i think i don't know 1200
replies
of people filling out the survey saying
they want to do this and so
yeah just that alone is kind of like to
your point here where
if you're a creator with an audience
with credibility if you've done
something if you're actually good at a
skill
yeah you can get to a million dollars a
year of profit
uh not just revenue doing it as an
individual course creator
yes and the path is quite
straightforward the tactics are
are simple but uh it's basically build
an audience that's
all has the most part that mostly has
yeah but even that
there's a process to that i mean it does
it's not it's not easy but it's simple
but you build up an audience where
people rally around one type of thing
and then you eventually
create something that costs 100 all the
way up to thousands of dollars and you
sell it
um my good friend one of my best friends
neville medora has done this with
copywriting he probably i don't know
what he makes but i
if he said a million dollars a year i
would think that sounds about right um
there's jack butcher like we said my
wife sarah is actually
launching one shawn has one i've
launched one
at the hustle before but it's not live
now but it was
and it's pretty interesting it's it's
the easiest path probably to make a
million bucks a year i actually think
and the way that you scale it's really
hard though now here's the downside
it's pretty hard i think to get past 10
million dollars a year in revenue on
that
not that like that should be the goal
necessarily but like it definitely caps
out
relatively low um but you could if you
as long as you don't base this on your
personality
it's a pretty good business that you
could sell to like private equity or
something like that for a bunch of money
and after you've created the course you
then create a consulting or coaching
service that costs 10 000 plus a year
and you could potentially have like a
pretty good 10 million to 20 million
your company i like that i'll give you
an example my uncle does this he's
in real estate he himself has like i
don't know a 200 something million
dollar real estate portfolio
so he created a basically how to get
into multi how to do multi-family
uh apartment investing and he creates a
course
the course i think is like five grand um
he sells a bunch of those and then out
of that some people pay him 25 grand for
like
the more one-on-one in-depth coaching
because they're like going at it
and for them it's not hard to justify
five or even twenty five thousand
dollars because
the economics of even a single apartment
building um that they're buying
are such that that's that's future what
cost
my uncle oh which uncle
uh my uncle i mean you don't know
you want you wanna you wanna pimp him
out though i'm trying to oh i don't even
know what his course is called he's
my uncle vinny we should have him on
he's got a kind of incredible story and
his personality is
amazing he's the most joyful person i've
ever known almost
to the point where people think he's
like are you high or something and he
but he's just like that 247 he's high on
life 24 7. it's kind of amazing
so uncle vinnie's a great example there
there's a good one
example of this now the second one that
i mentioned is like these master class
businesses
these companies there's a pretty clear
path to get to like a hundred million
dollars a year in sales
and what you do is you create something
that is
in the three 200 300 range for
an annual subscription and you
scale fast by buying a lot of ads um but
before you do that you have to create a
pretty big
library of course content which can take
many years
i know quite a bit about masterclass do
you want me to give you kind of like
some of the interesting bits
so master class they um
started by sky went to harvard business
school i believe um
and then he you know one of the core
insights was
he wanted to create what he said was the
library of alexandria for
um alexandria or alexandra basically
whatever the library was of like kind of
like all the best of human knowledge at
that time he basically was like i want
to create that of
today's time and so he they spend
upwards of half a million dollars per
masterclass just on the production value
alone even their first one was over 500
thousand dollars
and so the production value is like kind
of insane it's like a hollywood
shoot that they do personally i don't
even know if that's necessary i think
that's
that's totally overkill but that's their
stick the bigger part was that they got
the biggest brand name so they go
if you want to learn business well
here's howard schultz from the ceo of
starbucks you want to learn basketball
steph curry's master class you want to
learn comedy you're steve martin
you want to learn i don't know writing
here's aaron sorkin and so they took the
the a plus plus talent which is a key
differentiator right because
most of these online courses are like
you said it's me it's ramit safety it's
like these like
niche you know i'll just make fun of
myself here right we're nobodies in the
in the world compared to compared to
what masterclass went and did
and masterclass was like great i can
take
you know chef gordon ramsay's cooking
course
i can create a hype 30 second trailer
and i can
blast that on facebook ads and basically
gordon ramsay has enough brand
pull that i can profitably acquire
customers and so they do this with a
bunch of creators a bunch of different
um course creators serena williams
whoever else they cut a rev share deal
with them so they give them an upfront
kind of like minimum guarantee and then
they have like a rev share on
every course sold you know you get x and
then they turned it into like a class
past style subscription where now
you pay the 15 bucks a month you get
access to all of master class
and i actually talked to the founder the
ceo and i was like he's a great guy and
i was like
you know do people i took one and you
know but like
do people does does a person really want
to go learn cooking from gordon ramsay
and then basketball from this person
then tennis from serena williams like it
seems like
do i need the all-you-can-eat buffet and
like do i come back is the retention
high
and he just showed me the numbers he was
like look we're making x hundreds of
millions of dollars a year
it's growing at this pace and look at
the churn the churn's not so bad i said
how do you keep the churn so low like
for an education product like this he
goes
when people take a master class it's
they keep their subscription
even if they're not coming back and
taking a course every month why
because it's aspirational they they have
a dream of like learning photography
they want that hobby to exist they buy
the master class and if they have one
experience where they feel like their
hero or their idol kind of shared
like a real nugget of wisdom with them
um that's enough to keep them hooked
so i thought that was pretty interesting
and that's the thing that we should
discuss
that's the downside of this business as
well as every
other category that i'm mentioning is
and this is this freaks people out i
wouldn't even say
it's retention but it's completion so
our good friend nick hoover
launched the course and he goes dude 200
people bought this do you know how many
people
finished and did the whole thing he was
i i the number is
if it's not this exact number it's close
he's like three right
or something yeah it was like he was
like nothing and
i was like yeah man that's really normal
um he was being he was like he was legit
he was like dude did i make a shitty
course
i was like no this is the this is the
standard percentage completion if you go
to udemy i remember
with udemy i think they had said at one
point in time um
six percent of people complete the
course six percent right 100 students
come in
imagine on the last day of the semester
six people are left in the class
and so you know for nikes is pretty much
in line with like
this single digit completion rates that
was a big problem with education
and that sucks and actually i would
say two things one um for people getting
this business
just know that mo it's so weird that
you're gonna make all this money and
you're crushing it
most people don't even use the damn
thing and by the way they're not pissed
it's not that they used it because they
didn't like the product
often it's just life happened they got
busy they didn't follow through
they if they're upset at anyone they're
upset at themselves for not actually
taking the full action on the course
they're not upset with the course yeah
and just
counter intuitive the second thing here
is like is that even important is this
even a problem worth solving
and the answer i actually think
unfortunately is no
this is uh not a problem we're solving
people
aren't going to take it that is just how
people are and
we should move on and just make money
off of it because
just the fact that they buy that's
interesting and that kind of helps them
in a weird way
just like you with books just like you
at books it's like me with books yes
that's true but i would disagree in that
i do think it's the fight worth fighting
for because
if people aren't actually taking the
course ultimately they didn't get the
real value of the product
which means they're not going to come
back they're not going to tell friends
to do it which means your business is
gonna suffer
so can it be done can you get above six
percent ten percent can you can you get
thirty forty fifty percent dude even
that sounds crazy to me
i've asked um people who charge five
thousand dollars per course
they said uh under 30 is still what they
get as a completion rate it's insane
because that's such a big financial
commitment for people
um individually not out of their
company's pocket out of their own pocket
just to spend that money and not
complete it is insane to me but that's
what happens
now i will say though but when we had
cohort
classes like a live cohort class it was
like 75
completion exactly that's exactly what i
was about to say lambda school switched
to
live cohort based and with a um a clear
like sort of
uh high bar for entry so lambda school
most courses right when nick hoover
ramit and myself
when you sell the course you want pretty
much as many people as you can to take
the course that's how you make your
money right you're like a college
you want to admit as many people as you
can um unless you're the top college
where your brand is really about not
accepting everybody
and so similarly with lambda school
because lambda school doesn't get paid
until you get a job their incentive was
not to let any joe schmoe in
their incentive was dude we only want a
student if they're if we think they're
actually going to finish this course if
they're serious about it
and so because of the filter on the
front end plus the format being
live and in a peer group they had like
plus completion rates and then i
invested in this company
maven for the same reason because they
were saying hey we're going to make it
easy for you
to teach a cohort based course that was
appealing to me because i was like
so far cohort based courses is the only
thing i've seen where people actually
finish the course
so we'll see so but that is something
when we're going through this process we
or this discussion we have to
acknowledge that like
most people don't buy your stuff yeah
and if you're doing really well
like what did you say 70 yeah do it so
it's like kind of crazy that that's a
pretty nutty
nutty thing now to wrap up the master
class i don't
i have to call this like mass
consumerism course
category i don't know like lynda.com
would also be in this at the time now
linda's more b2b but
when linda started it was a place to go
learn anything right
um and and so lynda.com masterclass
there's a bunch of master class 4x so
it's like
there's a master class but instead of
steph curry and gordon ramsay
it's famous youtubers and they're called
monthly i think monthly.com
they're trying to do the same thing as
masterclass but their stars are social
media stars
and i think they were doing actually
pretty well there's another one that's
masterclass for athletes it's like okay
we're just going to take the vertical of
of sports and it was you know started by
exactly
that sounds neat um i just talked
to him the other day this would be a
perfect shout out for him
i apologize that i don't have it off top
of my hand but uh
but basically he he's a he's a trainer
he's a trainer for kyrie irving he's a
trainer for a bunch of nba stars
and so he's able to carmelo anthony so
he was able to say hey mello
create a create your course hey kyrie
create your course et cetera
and um and so he's able to access top
flight stars in basketball because he
himself is a basketball trainer
and create a master that's just of that
group just for that audience which i
thought was
actually a pretty interesting model
eight was his name
adam robin i'll find the name let me ask
ben real quick but yeah go on i'll get
the name
so anyway um in order to make that style
of business work
what you have to do is create a mostly
evergreen
course content and the name of the game
is get like basically as many as
possible that meet
some type of quality bar um right and
you just go big and try to create
hundreds of them or thousands of them
how do can you what the great courses is
one example i think they do like 150
million dollars a year in revenue
i don't know what master class is but i
bet you they're at 200 to 300-ish
yep um all right and then the fourth or
the third cat so i had three categories
i had like the small creator
i had tech stuff but we're gonna get rid
of the tech thing like udemy solo
solo teacher platform like you to me and
coursera
and then you had high-end um you know
library of of courses like masterclass
what else
now here's the fourth one and most
interesting one which is b2b
education corporate training type of
stuff easily the biggest one
hands down now an example of this is
pluralsight have you heard of
pluralsight
i've heard of it but i could i've heard
the name before but i couldn't have told
you what it did until this
beautiful lovely name it's geared
specifically towards engineers and it
just teaches like the latest and
greatest uh
um tech stuff that you you give to your
engineers and and they go through this
and uh pluralsight is one of them
there's actually a bunch of more a bunch
more and they there's many of them that
do 300 400 500
million dollars a year in revenue and
you but this is where it gets kind of
shitty
these businesses are based on one thing
salesmanship so you just hire a fat
sales team and you go out to these
companies and you sell
and i went and asked the people at
hubspot i go why do you guys buy this
stuff
and they actually told me all about it
and they're like well basically we're
ranked really high in glassdoor and we
recruit a ton of people
and one perk that we have is that we
give you five thousand dollars a year
uh for education now we could have
bought pluralsight but and that would
have actually solved the same thing
which is
we want to be the best place to work we
offer loads of perks like
we'll teach you x y and z um another
example of why these courses are
important is
something like cisco or microsoft have
tests and exams that they want you to
pass certifications
that they want you to pass in order to
either get a promotion or just you just
put it on your resume that you have this
interesting thing
pluralsight teaches you uh how to
succeed at those
uh at those um um
what am i saying at those uh
certifications
and they charge something like 600 a
year per head and you just got to hire a
sales team with the you give each
salesperson like a 300 000
500 000 quota and you go here's the
yellow pages
start dialing and and that's why
the pluralsight is based in utah because
the mormons are like some amazing sales
people because they've been they had to
spend two years selling a religion of
people
so they're really good at it um but this
business is probably the biggest
but i oddly it's really not
so much about the um it's not about
education it's not about education it's
about salesmanship
and the way that you win this um is you
you
you go down a very narrow knit niche you
hire subject
matter experts so people who know their
stuff you pay them a flat fee
sometimes royalty but you prefer to do a
flat fee because your gross margins will
be really really
uh a lot bigger and then you go very
niche you go very role specific and then
you go and you sell into the hr and then
learning
or learning and development budgets at
large companies which sucks because
uh those are typically the budgets that
are slashed first
but they're there and they have to get
spent and so pretty much it's a game
about getting inside with these people
and selling to them
kind of lame but there's money to be
made yeah i wonder if somebody could do
so so that's the way that most
corporate software was sold too until
slack and some others started this like
bottoms up
sales process inside companies where
they basically how it sold though uh it
isn't is it but there's so bottoms up
sass
became its own category where the model
was you make your software useful to
even if the whole company doesn't adopt
it
you let an individual person kind of the
front lines or the middle ranks of a
company
start using it they use it with their
team they're kind of like their sub team
other sub teams start using it and then
you go to the cio you have a meeting
with them and you say hey by the way
you know a bunch of your com a bunch of
your employees are using this thing you
need to buy the like
the enterprise version so that you have
like security stuff
like secured you have oversight over
what's going on
and that anybody in your company can get
access to this right now it's
everybody's putting down their own card
and trying to make this happen and so
that became a pretty popular model
yammer was one of the first to do it uh
then slack and others
um i wonder if this would be the only
way i would want to do it if i was an
entrepreneur going to space because i
wouldn't
really want to do the enterprise sales
path where
it's not really about the content it's
just about the sales you know how good
you are at sales as a company
um because if you go bottoms up you're
really going off of
making stuff that the individual
employees actually want to learn from
and then secondly you're only as good as
as them sort of
retaining or actually wanting to use
this so i think that's a healthy thing
in the end although it is
harder actually than the other path so i
wonder if there's a way to do that
the hard part here is just like there's
six percent completion rate for
hobbyists trying to learn i think
similarly
you know um for example i know that when
when the learning and development team
sends out an email
at twitch i asked my team i said hey do
you guys do any of these courses that
there's a bunch of free stuff available
here they pay for it you can just go
take it like
it could help you and they're like yeah
that's a good idea but like i just don't
have the time like everybody feels
overworked
so the amount of time an employee is
going to carve out to just do
optional education is so low that i just
think that most of the things that live
in the uh
what's it called the learning manager
whatever like the lms
learning management system inside
companies is uh untouched right it's
just twinkies sitting on a shelf
so that's exactly another that's another
thing so not only is it about
salesmanship
but basically these courses the truth is
it's not actually about teaching your
workers something good
it's about offering it and if they use
it fine
but the fact that you offer it it makes
you look better and you could hire more
people
um as i don't own my company anymore but
when i did i would never have bought the
i've been like look if you want to
take something
we'll buy you any book you want i'm not
but we're not paying for these stupid
courses because no one's going to use
them
but that's not how a big company thinks
because they want need to put it on
their
perks and benefits and here we are but
that is my
my very high level summary of this
course business i was very curious as to
how they work
um if i was well i am i'm not going to
launch any of the same time soon
but the first one the creator one
that's a that's a no-brainer it's a
no-brainer once you have an audience
right that's the
if you don't have an audience it's not
really going to work then then you're
more in one of the other buckets but
i think you correctly identified if you
have an audience it's a no-brainer
business model for people with audiences
but it also has a cap and it takes up
time so you gotta like
you know choose accordingly all right
let's talk about some other ideas
um i have one that i saw today that i
think is pretty interesting so
it's called the irish pub company did
you see this tweet no
so we got tagged in this which is by the
way that's the best signal that we're
doing something right is now
people just tag us in that they
know is the type of stuff we want to
talk about like we've built the brand of
like
when you hear about a cool niche
business that's crushing it that's like
so simple and you you would have
otherwise just never heard of this
it's like this is perfect for my first
million so somebody tagged us oh this is
awesome our friend um chris
uh chris j becky is his like handle i
don't know if it's becky or bach i don't
know how you say it i think it's bach
um he tweeted this out so so shout out
to chris he was on the podcast a while
back
he's a super entertaining guy on twitter
you should follow him
so one of the things he said is he said
the irish pub company is one of my
favorite companies
they charge one to four million dollars
for a irish bar in a box
which basically means it's an irish bar
as a service so
here's how it works um they give you you
know like they have like six styles to
choose from of which style of irish bar
and they give you like
the guinness signs the the right bar tap
handles
you know that kind of like all the decor
the seats the the the stuff like that
and they they ship it all to you and
they install it for you and like
bang now you have an irish pub and i
think this is such an amazing business
so
they've done over 2 2000 kits and it's
about one to four million dollars per
kit according to him so i haven't
this this happened like two minutes
before the pods i didn't research too
much more but
that's over 30 years that's 2 billion
over 30 years that this company has
generated
just selling the irish bar in a box and
um and what they say if you go to their
website is like
you know hey uh like the here's the
stats right like the
uh irish pubs produce you know x more
revenue
than a traditional bar and has this much
more foot traffic and basically it's
saying hey
if you if you throw this kit onto a
generic bar your bar is more successful
it'll pay itself back
uh what do you think of this business so
the owner's name is
mel mcnally which is like the perfect
perfect
got him um he's the founder of irish pub
company he's the creator of the guinness
irish pub concept so he launched this in
partnership with guinness brewery
brewing which is basically i'm just
reading the about page
sounds to me like dennis was like hey we
need more irish pubs to exist in this
world
okay so we can sell more ir irish beer
and get us beer can someone uh
come and help us figure this out and
that's what he partnered with
uh or that's how we started this awesome
awesome awesome
this is so cool i love this um
it's crazy they're making i mean i think
just looking at the numbers if these
numbers on their website are accurate i
think they're doing like 50 million
dollars plus a year
um doing this just like the consulting
the brand identity then the like insta
the shipping and the installation and
then the service after that
um dude it's pretty pretty awesome how'd
they do it inside
airports they do it in you know just
different cities hotels different stuff
like that
how did your buddy find this i have no
idea he just tweeted it out
um so it's great i don't know i think
this is such a cool concept and then you
can think about like okay
how many more concepts are there like
this right so like
i i can think of if you take any
sort of like sub genre the question is
is there a market for that so i'll give
you
let's just brainstorm for a second right
well there's one one great example that
you brought up a long time
or a year ago that i think is probably
killing it and that was
bathroom in a box yes made renovations
yes all they do you select one of five
different bathrooms and they come and
make it
you can obviously do this for every
single room in the home but then
we talked about the guys who came and
set up our video conferencing setup that
you know this good looking setup that we
have right now with the lighting the
audio the
dslr camera have the whole tech is set
up the wires are
you know taped to my table so i don't
have a wire mess i told the guys i said
hey
you need to turn this into home home
video conferencing home studio in a box
right you could you could do just like
the bathroom guys did you could do this
in every city in america right now
especially with remote with podcasters
and twitch streamers and youtubers
a lot of people want a cool video set up
and if you just have four to choose from
on your menu
now you have simple operations you have
scale as you buy parts in bulk
that sort of thing so i think that's
another version of this um
but just in the bar concept i think that
there's a few more
so i think that any brand with licensed
ips so like
okay you can't like you could you do but
could you do this for basically disney
could you do a disney diner
right um so you take ip that people love
and you create a bar restaurant out of
it right so like sort of rainforest cafe
style
and you just sell that as a in a box
concept for any
um common thing coffee shops diners
pubs aren't you confusing
this whatever this in a box concept is
compared to
franchises so it's not france so this
the idea would be
you would partner with um let's say i
don't know let's call it the simpsons
you partner with the simpsons franchise
and you say hey look for every one of
these
wouldn't it be great if you could have
you know i forgot what the bar is called
in the simpsons but like
whatever that you know wherever moe
works or whatever yeah or do paddy's pub
yeah exactly you go to always sunday and
you can basically have paddy's pub in a
box and every city should have a paddy's
pub and whatever
and um so you go and you say every one
of these we sell you guys get ten
percent you gotta do nothing more than
let us use the name paddy's pub and
you know the the same items we're going
to source and now you go to bars and you
say hey look
you as a generic bar you're only pull
you have no like differentiation of why
tourists should come here why the locals
should choose you
can you upgrade and so i think that
there's a bunch of different
concepts that would work with this so i
think one is gaming
gamers have like a deep passion
and and so there's been i i lived in
denver and there were some bars like
this where it was like
the bar had like some old school retro
arcade machines
all the drinks and menus looked you know
like video game like you know old
nintendo stuff
and then they had like you know
life-size jenga or whatever right but it
was a place to go hang out
you could play skee-ball you could do
whatever and they just got way more foot
traffic than a normal bar why because
this one you would go to and you would
have
instagram worthy experiences right you
would post in your story that you're
drinking you know the mario drink while
playing whatever duck hunt or skee ball
or whatever it is
and so i think gaming is one niche
that's like an irish pub
that you could show that hey if you if
you kit your bar out with this you're
gonna get more foot traffic and more
sales
i would need to think about which which
of these could work but whatever this
in a box thing it's kind of interesting
i had a friend that did book in a box
and they would write a book for you i
think it was making eight figures in
revenue but it sounded like a
real pain in the ass because it was
it was far too customizable to be in a
box whereas
a pub thing probably isn't that's way
easier that's like saying like
you got runny water you got uh you know
this many dimensions
well this is basically just a set like
it's one interior
decoration like theme that you just slap
on and boom you got an irish pub now you
don't you had a pub now you got an irish
pub
and so i just wonder you know a could
you just compete with them or b
are there other themes that are even if
they're not as popular as an irish pub
like what's the second most popular kind
of like
is it german is it you know an asian
style pub is it a russian drinking bar
is that i don't know i don't know i
think like is it a mexican
tequila bar is it you know what what is
it that that is it an italian wine bar i
don't know
i don't know you're asking a non-drinker
i'm i'm out of the loop on this one
i do have a different idea that i think
is kind of
interesting to chat about so uh clear
ice have you ever heard of clear ice
hmm what is it this to me feels like
if you're um i'll find you the url go to
clearice.life
so cleareyes.life so this is not
something i would do but i've learned
that
these things where i just shake my head
i'm like who the wants to do this
i learned like the hard way that like
three years later it's like yeah
this is like this is like a hobby that a
lot of people have that's like
growing like crazy so here's the other
examples of this you know like
sodastream
i think you probably do sodastream right
dude i have a video on tic toc one of
the only videos i ever posted it got
like 200 000 views because i attached a
like a scuba tank size co2 thing i
rigged it to my soda stream so it could
last like three years versus having to
constantly replace the things yeah i
love sodastream so the first time i
heard this i was like oh you like make
your own sparkling water at home like
what's the point of that like
sodastream is like a 5 billion a year
company or something i know that's my
point is that when i heard i was like
who would wanna why is this a hobby who
wants to do this at home why is this a
diy
category but it was it was a huge
category and like you know got bigger
and bigger
craft beer same thing i remember like a
decade ago these guys were like brewing
their own beers and i was like why
there's so many beers i don't just go
buy some and then like over time more
and more home brewers and craft beer
dude have you ever met a white guy
before like that's like like
there's two things that you you there's
a two jokes about uh white people they
always have bottle openers on them and
they love baking their own beer at home
yeah basically actually this category is
just i observe white people do
and i'm confused about uh so another one
like there's this there's a bunch of
these like with pour over coffees and
like these like really extreme coffee
habits that people have
anyways there's a whole bunch of these
these little niche
hobbies of diy things that i don't
understand but they
definitely are big and then they create
a whole ecosystem of businesses around
them
so clear ice is the latest one i saw
that i was like this basically what is
clear ice
clear ice is basically like i'm idea i
might not even fully understand this
it's that's how white this is okay so
you you translate this for me what i
understand is
it's like a it's like an amazing piece
of ice so not just the you get out
of your fridge
or your little tray or the stuff you buy
in a bag
but it's like this is high quality it's
like super clear like
there's no um you know impairments or
like kind of
stuff in it so it doesn't flavor your if
you're drinking whiskey it won't like
affect the flavor of your whiskey
it's also one big cube so there's less
surface area so it dilutes
uh less it doesn't dilute your drink
less well you knew that right
i didn't think about this stuff i don't
care i just put the ice in i drink my
drink when it gets diluted i drink it
it's kind of gross i haven't it's like
they sell it like yeah yeah they like
sell these like
cubes or balls and they yeah it involves
surface area and melting
and diluting your slower right and
so
so anyways this hobby this is like some
that you would find in the
hustle trends thing this is my own
little contribution to trends
uh you know if steph smith if you're
listening put this in the news like go
research this
my spidey sense is tingling that this is
one of those little niche hobbies
that you could sell products information
courses whatever
and there's a lot of people that want to
make their own homemade ice
again i can barely understand why but
it's a thing that people are doing
and i bet you that there's a uh a
movement to be had or a sort of
a wave to surf if you want to build a
business around this super niche but a
hobbyist business
dude no i don't i'm not on board with
this i think this is stupid
i think why first of all is this even
that big
it's clear i saw it as part of like a
growing trend i don't know if it was a
subreddit or where i saw
it but i saw it in a way that was like
oh this is one of those
that's like popular and i don't
understand why like it's like asmr it's
like what is that
uh asmr is awesome so don't
you better be careful that's how me at
the beginning when i'm like this is
weird people do this and then like yeah
a lot of people want this and do this
yeah look i i'm looking around on google
i get it
to me this sounds like a pretty tiny
thing but
like tiny enough that you could make
like a pretty good living doing it
though
like i knew yeah all you want to do is
you want to catch these early right like
you wanted to you want to catch it when
it's
somewhat tiny but like very passionate
because the bet you're making is that
that passion the tiny the passion will
stay and the tiny will not
right that's pretty consistent uh is
that when you have the passion there
passion stays and tiny go becomes
medium-sized becomes large over time
yeah i guess it could work i mean i'm
looking i'm trying to like look it up
i mean there was this other one there
was a home brewery company that i
that i i for a long time i didn't know
that like
people basically beer nerds like track
all the beers that they've ever tried
and i interviewed a guy to work at the
hustle and he worked at one of these
companies and it was like a
tens of millions maybe even close to
hundreds of millions of dollar revenue
business and all it was was an app where
you could track all the beers that you
uh drink um so put that in that category
of things i have no idea exists and
also kind of they don't excite me
[Laughter]
all right let's do let's do one more
real quick um
okay here's one that i'm just curious i
don't have ideas around this just yet
but let's
let's do a off-the-cuff brainstorm so
there's this article that came out
that was about uh i'll share it with you
here it's about
the amount of space that is now
available in san francisco
because of like work from home so there
is some absurd amount
of vacant space so there's like
companies that are
taking 10 or even 100 million dollar
write-offs on their real estate just to
like
get out of it and move on and so they're
just they're just writing it down so
like
here's some of the the numbers um
i mean so there's 200 million dollars of
real estate impairments
in the past year since covid it's almost
a billion if you add in the least
related write-downs from large companies
like salesforce dropbox
uber paypal zendesk just getting rid of
their their
uh real estate and so um dropbox itself
has 400 million dollars of impaired real
estate right now
and so they think that by you know in
this quarter or the first quarter of
sorry the last quarter of 2021 the
amount of vacant and subleasable space
was 10 million square feet in 2021.
in 2019 that was three million right so
it's tripled the amount of available
um subleasable squares uh square footage
and
the companies are basically saying hey
this is it costs us 90
we'll take 20 for it so you're able to
get real estate
for you know one fourth of the of the
traditional cost now we're talking this
is a good idea yes this is an
interesting
real estate so what comes to mind what
what do you think of when you hear about
kind of this
this opening that's in the market okay
for the sake of discussion let's just
assume that they like san francisco has
a bunch of wacky laws
like um right um i mean like you all
can't do with things
yeah and they also have like some really
crazy tendent uh um
what's it called rent controlled stuff
so let's just assume that like
we're gonna research these laws later
and and that isn't that big let's assume
we're never going to research these laws
that's really interesting um but so what
could you do with this
arbitrage i mean the obvious answer is
like wework can make a killing right now
if they believe in their model can they
can they just go ahead and like do the
thing where they uh
lease a lot of it up front and hopefully
they can fill it but
what else could you do with this i don't
know man that's a hard question what
would you do
i don't know i think you have to see
what um
what i think you want to think about
this way
where is demand growing for space that
being
central in a city would now make a very
big difference cloud solutions
cloud kitchens cloud grocery and
convenience
uh like cloud cloud corner stores
basically like um
fridge no more or something like that i
think those are kind of interesting
because
go puff because you have a whole bunch
of people in the city and now when they
push the button they get their thing in
under 10 minutes
because it was they took a floor in the
bottom of the salesforce tower
you know the second floor is now all you
know
robo convenience stores that will just
quickly deliver to you
so i think you have to find something
like that maybe it is
wework style you know kind of um
co-working spaces
but there's got to be something else
that you would do with this primo real
estate maybe there's something in
education that
you know you create a distributed campus
or something like that
um across a whole bunch of different
cities and so you know you take a
business school
i do you know take harvard business
school online which they have
and you basically say great you can
attend harvard business school online
in san francisco downtown in la downtown
in all these places because
that's where that type of clientele
wants and now you get
a once in a lifetime opportunity to lock
up that real estate at a fourth of the
cost i don't know those are some just
random ideas off
that is a i think that's quite an
interesting idea of
that that's actually a good idea because
that would yeah some you know like the
equivalent of a study abroad
but you're just going to do it in san
francisco which prohibit was
prohibitedly expensive for the longest
time
that is actually kind of an interesting
idea um
so what do you know what the price per
square foot is right now
in this they were 25 they were saying 20
a square foot
um which is like that's an annual number
right so it
would have been 90 a square foot
annually and now 20 is kind of what's
quoted in this
uh cnbc article do you know how that
compares to like an
austin like a more like a sea level city
i don't know i think that is like
what i think that would be like what a
mid-level city would have been
um without the pandemic that's my guess
is something like that i think san
francisco was four or four to five times
more expensive
per square foot um than than you know a
b-level city
you know i think that i've been living
in austin now for
just a handful of months i miss san
francisco dearly i do think that if
you're starting a company now
um and you have like a good sized
workforce
it would be interesting to try to kind
of sign a lease now that you can book
out for five or ten years i do like it's
gonna roar back i think eventually
um i mean i think that's the opportunity
here's another one
let's say you're it was random let's say
you're a venture fund
or late stage venture fund
what if you took the real estate and
then basically any of your companies can
just use this
and pay you the you know pay you market
rent or slightly above
maybe slightly below so all your
portfolio companies now have their real
estate problem
uh solved and you know you could place
them because of that
dude people were on wework
myself included
i think now it's like this this makes
sense in a lot of these cities these we
the weworks of the world and not only
that i think that they're just going to
come back like crazy
because every employee says the exact
same thing well i would love to work
from home for a few days a week
yeah exactly it's like well dog i can't
pay rep few days a week
uh if i have my own lease right i'd love
to die a few days a week
yeah so i think that like the the
saunders of the world and a bunch of
these other companies that didn't do so
hot
uh for the last two years i think they
they absolutely can be started right now
and i think it sounds crazy
crazy to start him right now but i don't
think it is even a little bit bro i
loaded up on airbnb stock today
oh my gosh i'm devastated i i'm seeing
it go down
what is it at now it's going down
because the lockup period ended i don't
know if you guys sold
your shares or not but the lock-up
period ended so people could start
selling so put a bunch of downward
pressure on the stock
plus the market in general wait did it
end i thought
oh did it end i didn't even know i
thought it ended in june that ends in
june
i think it's six months for something
for i think for some insiders at least
uh they can dump they can jump today why
on earth would you ever dump airbnb
stock right now
but i bought it because uh hey i just
i'm stupid i just buy stocks when i feel
like it but b
um i saw some data that was showing how
a huge amount of airbnb bookings i think
28 30 percent
are um actually i don't remember the
percentages
it's a very large percentage of airbnb
revenue or bookings was coming from
stays longer than 30 days now um
which means that it's actually not
vacation rentals only
you know it's actually millennials just
saying ah i want to stay here for a
little while
which is like i think a pretty big trend
of i don't want to be i don't want to
buy i don't even want a one year lease
that's too much
commitment how do i hop from place to
place similar to what you did
last year uh dude so many 28-day plus
stays
i think that is actually an interesting
trend that people should take advantage
of and we actually have a guy coming on
the podcast
um named bill smith i guess his name is
like a real generic name he started
shipped
which sold for like 600 million dollars
based on alabama it was like an
instagram
he's got this new company called uh
landing
is you know i'm talking about yes uh
what's the url it's called like landing
home or something
home landing uh but anyway what it is is
they lease out
apartments in different places and they
take the whole lease and then they
sublease it because for people want to
stay for a month and the thing about
airbnb
is that they actually charge what's the
fee 10
if you're saying for two weeks if you're
staying like in new york like i'm gonna
be staying i'm moving to new york for
three or four months
uh it's prohibitively expensive so if my
rent is 10 grand a month i'm paying
a thousand dollars a month just in
airbnb fees and so i could figure out
how to reduce that fee to something that
makes sense for the longer term
i think that in the future people like
us um
and maybe a little bit younger i think
it's gonna be incredibly normal to live
somewhere for nine months and somewhere
for three months
right and so if they can figure that out
it's huge but do you agree that
like if you would you consider living
somewhere for three months out of the
year
for sure i plan to do that yeah where
are you gonna go like i got like a
little baby right now so it's just a
little bit tricky but yeah that's that's
the lifestyle i'm gonna live is
living in one place and then the other
place for two to three months out of the
year
without sounding like a total douche is
this a rich guy thing or do you think
that like lots of people are going to be
doing it
well you could do it you could do it
economically like i know a lot of people
that did this and made money doing it
right it wasn't a rich guy thing they
went
they live in san francisco predominantly
and then they sub they they airbnb their
san francisco place for a month
and they go live in a you know mexico or
south america
and actually they make money for
traveling because
the san francisco airbnb costs more
they're able to charge more for that
than they
pay in south america my lease or not at
least my
uh mortgage and insurance and everything
at my house costs about 4 500
a month and i think that we're gonna get
about 10 grand a month when we rent it
out um
and we're gonna use and then we're we've
already booked a place we're living in
brooklyn i'm living in brooklyn from
july to
september and so and i plan on doing
that indefinitely and i think a lot of
people are gonna be doing that as well
cool um i gotta run i gotta get out of
here but
good episode we're out
i feel like i can rule the world i know
i could be
what i want to i
never looking back